As the crispy chicken sandwich from 7-Eleven, people always call me loud. And I'm like, yeah, I know. I'm crispy. Did you expect me to whisper? If you want quiet, go eat some soup and reflect. Like, I know I'm a handful. I'm bold, I'm juicy. Throw some pickles and barbecue sauce on me, and baby, I'm a whole meal.
作为7-Eleven的脆皮鸡三明治，人们总说我声音很大。我心想，是啊，我知道。我很脆。难道你指望我低声细语吗？如果你想要安静，去喝点汤反思一下吧。我知道我很难搞。我大胆，我多汁。给我加点酸黄瓜和烧烤酱，宝贝，我就是一顿完整的大餐。
And with seven rewards, I'm just $4. Quiet. No. Krispy, saucy, and $4? Very. Only at 711. Valley 362326, participating stores only while supplies lastly out for full terms. Changing how people perceive and receive mental health services is not an easy task.
有了7-Eleven的奖励，我只要4美元。安静？不。脆皮、多汁、只要4美元？非常可以。仅限7-Eleven。优惠至362326，仅限参与门店，售完即止，详情请见完整条款。改变人们对心理健康服务的认知和获取方式并非易事。
The stigma associated with mental illness remains a difficult barrier for many. But we speak with a psychologist who is making mental health services, trainings, and screenings more accessible to people in one city. He hopes other cities and towns will follow his lead. I'm Audrey Hamilton and this is Speaking of Psychology. Arthur Evans is the Commissioner of Philadelphia's Department of Behavioral Health. and intellectual disability services. A clinical and community psychologist, Dr. Evans, focuses his work on improving treatment options
与精神疾病相关的污名化对许多人来说仍然是一个难以逾越的障碍。但我们采访了一位心理学家，他正在让一个城市的心理健康服务、培训和筛查变得更加普及。他希望其他城市和城镇也能效仿。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。亚瑟·埃文斯是费城行为健康与智力残疾服务部的专员。作为一名临床和社区心理学家，埃文斯博士致力于改善治疗方案，
for people suffering from addiction and other mental illnesses. Welcome, Dr. Evans. Thank you. I'm glad to be here. One of your major initiatives with the city of Philadelphia is to change how people perceive and receive community mental health services. Can you tell us about some of the ways you're doing that? Sure. I think it's one of the most important things that we can do right now as a field.
为那些受成瘾和其他精神疾病困扰的人提供帮助。欢迎您，埃文斯博士。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。您在费城的主要举措之一是改变人们感知和获取社区心理健康服务的方式。您能告诉我们您是如何做到这一点的吗？当然。我认为这是我们目前作为该领域从业者所能做的最重要的事情之一。
as the country is really dealing with the issue of mental health, how do people access services, how do people get what they need? One of the things that we realize and recognize is that people have very strong views about mental illness. There are stigma around that, and we feel strongly that if we're really going to help people, we not only need to make sure that the services are there, but people are actually going to reach out for those services. So we're using a variety of methods to do that.
随着全国都在真正应对心理健康问题，人们如何获取服务，人们如何得到他们所需要的？我们意识到并认识到的一点是，人们对精神疾病有着非常强烈的看法。这周围存在污名化，我们坚信，如果我们真的想帮助人们，我们不仅需要确保服务到位，还要确保人们真的会去寻求这些服务。所以我们正在使用各种方法来实现这一目标。
Can you give us an example of how you're doing that? Sure. So one of them that we recently just did implement it was to implement a mental health screening kiosk in a retail pharmacy. So what does that mean? That means that next to the blood pressure cuff at your local pharmacy, you will be able to take a mental health screening. And it takes about five minutes at the most. It gives you information and feedback on whether or not you are likely to have a mental health condition. not to diagnose, it's not to give you a diagnosis or that kind of thing, but it's to say, you know, your symptoms, what you're reporting to us is consistent with depression or anxiety disorder or PTSD, and here's some resources that you can reach out to for help. So next to, for example, the blood pressure cuff that you're saying to is not going to tell
您能给我们举个例子说明您是如何做到的吗？当然。我们最近实施的一项措施是在零售药店安装心理健康筛查亭。这是什么意思呢？这意味着在当地药店的血压计旁边，你将能够进行心理健康筛查。最多只需要五分钟。它会为你提供关于你是否可能患有心理健康状况的信息和反馈。这不是为了诊断，不是为了给你一个诊断结果之类的，而是为了告诉你，你知道，你向我们报告的症状与抑郁症、焦虑症或创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）相符，这里有一些你可以寻求帮助的资源。所以，比如在血压计旁边，你说的并不是要告诉你
you whether or not you have heart disease. Exactly. But it may give you indication that you could be going that way. Absolutely. And like a blood pressure cuff, the idea is, again, not to do. diagnose yourself, but to find out whether or not you should seek help from your physician. And in this way, what people are doing is finding out if they should seek help from a mental health professional. We're very excited. It's the first time it's been done in the country.
你是否患有心脏病。没错。但它可能会给你一个迹象，表明你可能正朝着那个方向发展。绝对是这样。就像血压计一样，我们的想法同样不是让你自我诊断，而是让你找出是否应该向医生寻求帮助。通过这种方式，人们正在发现他们是否应该向心理健康专业人士寻求帮助。我们非常兴奋。这是全国首次这样做。
Our goal is to work with pharmacies around the city to get them to do this, and we think we're going to be successful with that. Now, this is surprising even to me. According to the National Alliance on Mental Illness, more than 57 million people will be diagnosed with a mental health disorder this year. That's a large number, and too many of them will not seek mental health services. How can psychologists within communities help to reduce the stigma associated with treatment, especially treatment for addiction, for example? Sure. So I think one of the most important things is that we demystify what we do. I think it's essential. I often talk about our field working on a black box principle, meaning that we
我们的目标是与全市的药店合作，让他们开展这项工作，我们认为我们会取得成功。现在，这甚至让我感到惊讶。根据美国国家精神疾病联盟的数据，今年将有超过5700万人被诊断出患有心理健康障碍。这是一个巨大的数字，其中太多人不会寻求心理健康服务。社区内的心理学家如何帮助减少与治疗相关的污名化，特别是针对成瘾的治疗？当然。所以我认为最重要的事情之一就是让我们所做的工作去神秘化。我认为这至关重要。我经常谈到我们的领域是在“黑箱”原则下运作的，这意味着我们
have treatment programs or private practice offices, they are sort of a mystery to the community. People see those programs. And one of the things we're doing in Philadelphia to try to address that is we as a payer of those services say to our providers, you really have to be a part of the community, not just in the community. And what that means is we expect that people are going to do outreach, that they're going to do community screenings, that they're going to do education, They're going to invite people in for various kinds of events. And the providers who do that have, I think, recognized that by doing that, they are perceived much differently. People are much more willing to reach out to them when they need help.
有治疗项目或私人诊所，它们对社区来说是一种谜。人们看到了这些项目。我们在费城尝试解决这个问题的方法之一是，作为这些服务的支付方，我们对提供者说，你们真的必须成为社区的一部分，而不仅仅是存在于社区中。这意味着我们期望人们进行外展活动，进行社区筛查，进行教育，邀请人们参加各种活动。我认为，这样做的人已经认识到，通过这样做，他们被看待的方式大不相同。当人们需要帮助时，他们更愿意向他们求助。
And I think as a general rule, that's something that we need to do as a profession, is to get out of what I, again, I call our black boxes, our treatment programs, our offices, get into communities, let people see us in a different kind of role, and I think it goes a long way in helping to reduce the stigma. Do you think the Affordable Care Act, which was implemented by the Obama administration, is it doing its part in making more mental health services available to people who need them? Have you noticed this? Yes, well, absolutely, because one of the, you know, if you look at the number of people who have a
我认为作为一条普遍规则，这是我们需要作为专业人士去做的事情，那就是走出我所说的“黑箱”，即我们的治疗项目和办公室，走进社区，让人们以不同的角色看到我们，我认为这在帮助减少污名化方面大有裨益。你认为奥巴马政府实施的《平价医疗法案》在为需要的人提供更多心理健康服务方面发挥了作用吗？你注意到了吗？是的，当然，因为其中一个，你知道，如果你看看那些有
diagnosable mental disorder. You look at the number of people who do not seek treatment. One of the big reasons is that people don't have health insurance. And I think one of the things that I think many of us in the field are excited about is that the ACA for the first time is going to make sure that millions of people in this country have access to health care. That in turn allows them to then have access to mental health care. So I think it's going to play a big role in us getting to literally millions of people who
可诊断精神障碍的人数。你看看那些不寻求治疗的人数。其中一个主要原因是人们没有医疗保险。我认为我们领域中的许多人感到兴奋的一点是，《平价医疗法案》首次确保了全国数以百万计的人能够获得医疗保健。这反过来又使他们能够获得心理健康护理。所以我认为它将在我们真正接触到数以百万计的人方面发挥巨大作用，
who currently need our services but are not accessing them. I'm interested in hearing more about a program you support called Mental Health First Aid. You tell us about this program why you think it's important to implement something like that now. Sure. Mental Health First Aid is a one-day training course that really helps the general public understand mental illness, understand or recognize when someone might be having a mental health problem, and know how to support the person and or refer the person.
他们目前需要我们的服务但却没有获得。我有兴趣听听更多关于你支持的名为“心理健康急救”的项目。你能告诉我们这个项目吗？为什么你认为现在实施这样的项目很重要？当然。“心理健康急救”是一个为期一天的培训课程，它真正帮助公众了解精神疾病，理解或识别某人何时可能出现心理健康问题，并知道如何支持该人或转介该人
for other help or to seek self-help. We are tremendously excited about it. The response that we've gotten to our efforts to train people within the city has been really overwhelming. Our goal right now is to train 10,000 people by the end of next year. And what's exciting about that is you think about even a large city like Philadelphia, to have 10,000 people in our community that are better able to recognize when a person is having a mental health challenge, know how to respond, is very exciting. You know, if you're in a restaurant and someone has a heart attack, there'll probably be five
去寻求其他帮助或寻求自助。我们对此感到非常兴奋。我们为培训市内人员所做的努力得到的反馈确实令人难以置信。我们目前的目标是在明年年底前培训10,000人。令人兴奋的是，即使是在费城这样的大城市，社区里有10,000人能够更好地识别某人何时面临心理健康挑战，并知道如何应对，这是非常令人兴奋的。你知道，如果你在餐馆里，有人心脏病发作，可能会有五
or six people can jump up and do CPR. If you're in a restaurant and someone starts to exhibit psychiatric symptoms, most people run the other way. And so what mental health first aid does is it really gives, you know, the average person the ability or the skills and the confidence to help people in those instances. And so it's been very well received by a broad cross-section of people in our city, from people in our criminal justice system to people in our schools, to people in corporate America. People, regardless of where they are,
或六个人跳出来进行心肺复苏。如果你在餐馆里，有人开始表现出精神症状，大多数人会往反方向跑。所以“心理健康急救”所做的，就是真正赋予普通人帮助这些情况下的他人的能力或技能和信心。因此，它受到了我们城市各界人士的广泛欢迎，从刑事司法系统的人员到学校的人员，再到企业界的人员。无论人们身处何地，
recognize that these are issues that affect lots of people and that they need help in addressing those issues. If you know someone who you think has a, mental disorder or if you're concerned about your own mental health. You know, what are the first steps a person should take to find the right diagnosis and treatment? Sure. So I think that varies a lot depending on what community you're in. If you're in Philadelphia, for example, we have a number of hotlines and numbers that you can call. There's a suicide hotline. We have a hotline for people who are in psychiatric crisis. We have information lines. For example, we have a website that we
他们都认识到这些问题影响着许多人，并且他们需要帮助来解决这些问题。如果你认识的人你认为有精神障碍，或者如果你担心自己的心理健康。你知道，一个人应该采取的第一步是什么来找到正确的诊断和治疗？当然。所以我认为这取决于你所在的社区。例如，在费城，我们有许多热线和电话号码可以拨打。有自杀热线。我们有为处于精神危机中的人提供的热线。我们有信息热线。例如，我们有一个网站，我们
created that is called Healthy Mindsfilly.com. And we created that website because we wanted to have a place that people could go on the website that was very accessible, that was destigmatized in a lot of ways. It's, you know, very colorful and accessible. And we put a lot of information out there, mental health screening, information about mental health first aid, information about how you access services. And those kinds of resources, I think help people to reach out for help. If you're in a community, most communities do have a suicide hotline. Most communities do have an information line.
创建了它，叫做HealthyMindsPhilly.com。我们创建该网站是因为我们希望有一个人们可以访问的地方，它非常易于访问，并且在很多方面消除了污名化。它非常丰富多彩且易于访问。我们发布了很多信息，心理健康筛查、关于心理健康急救的信息、关于如何获取服务的信息。我认为这些资源可以帮助人们寻求帮助。如果你在一个社区，大多数社区确实有自杀热线。大多数社区确实有信息热线。
There's a national website called Network of Care, which is in many cities and states around the country. And that is a, so if you Google Network of Care in your town or your state, in many states, you will find a website that will give you information on services in your state. in your community. So I would say, you know, unfortunately, unlike physical health care where people know
有一个名为“护理网络”（Network of Care）的全国性网站，它遍布全国许多城市和州。所以，如果你在你的城镇或州搜索“Network of Care”，在许多州，你会找到一个网站，它会提供关于你所在州、你所在社区的服务信息。所以我认为，你知道，不幸的是，与人们知道
where the local hospital is and often have a relationship with a primary care provider, when it comes to mental health, people typically don't have those kinds of ongoing relationships. And so it takes a little bit of digging depending on what neighborhood or what community you're in. Okay, Dr. Evans, thank you so much for joining us. Well, thank you. I appreciate, and I've had a great time. Thank you.
当地医院在哪里并且通常与初级保健提供者有联系的身体健康护理不同，当谈到心理健康时，人们通常没有那种持续的关系。因此，这需要根据你所在的社区或邻里进行一点挖掘。好的，埃文斯博士，非常感谢您加入我们。好的，谢谢。我很感激，我度过了一段美好的时光。谢谢。
For more information on Dr. Evans' initiatives, please, go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有关埃文斯博士倡议的更多信息，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。与美国心理学会合作，《心理学谈话》，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。